oh no
good night dr hawking
carbon boron beryllium lithium helium
hydrogen
nailed it
carry the four oh gosh hey there tabitha
it's the good night show live from your
bedroom starring dad and mom
and special guest baby good goodnight
little tina
come back here good night mom
good night sweetheart
good night song with your dad well it's
time for your goodnight song
oh no thanks i'm listening to white
noise
helps me fall asleep
hey what would you say to me helping you
rehearse for the holiday pageant
yes right i can come to school with you
and you can get all your friends
together and we can rehearse together
go get some ice cream after my treat no
you can't do that
um liability issues it's this whole
thing
oh right right right
whoa how about your favorite bedtime
story
you know the one about uncle ted was a
magical talking baby
there was a rocket for all the puppies
and you saved the wish
it was a good story wasn't it well it
didn't really make a lot of sense
the jokes were good right
okay uh dad my schedule is
brutal tomorrow yeah my schedule's
pretty brutal dude
oh don't forget lamb lamb good night
lamb loom
good night uncle ted i hope to grow up
and be a success just like you
maybe we'll see you soon
good
don't night think i'm a little old for
that now
uh okay i think it's time we both grow
up
i look forward to greeting you at the
breakfast table
sweet dreams
hmm
where is the time gone how should i know
at long last the sweet breath of freedom
was he you know what century is this oh
unhand me vile oh god no no no lizzy
it's me it's damn
is it really you come closer
let me see your face closer
closer still oh timothy
it is you hey what was that for you
cast me into eternal darkness and wreak
hammock on my circadian rhythms
i'm sorry wizzy hey you look great
though
except for the arm you mean i didn't
even notice you caught it
i mean i noticed because then you
obviously don't have an arm i you will
never
treat lam lam this way well i i gave her
to my daughter
tabitha you have produced an air timothy
two actually two let the bells a ring
i don't know i guess i'm just not
feeling very celebratory
right now oh
tabitha man wizzy she's
growing up so fast it's like she doesn't
even need me anymore
yes first they start spending less time
with you
hmm then they stop coming to you for
advice
exactly soon they take you for granted
i guess then break your arm what
and stuff you into a box okay lizzy
you're not helping
okay i'm just i'm afraid tabitha and i
are growing apart
like like i did with my brother
oh i thought we had all the time in the
world
but you can't turn back time can you how
dare you
question my power turn back now
turn back oh great wheel of luck
did you hear that never abuse the snooze
button
it sounds like it's coming from the
baby's room what is it a creature of the
night
witches is it the bang of the hounds of
hell where is he
i can turn back time to the golden years
when it was
just you and me my
[Music]
[Music]
hang up and then dial your operator
thank you
hello if you would like to make a call
please hang up and try again
just my phone get it together man
oh tina you little klepto
[Music]
is that you
you can talk yeah i'm in the family
business it's a clip-on tie
you see daddy baby corp is more like
oops daddy daddy come in
can you hear me daddy do you read me
daddy how many fingers i'm holding up
thursday i should have given you a
warning i forgot you were an old man
wait wait you're from baby core yes
baby corp is more of what i call a side
hustle for me
the point is i'm all in on the temple
tends to go oh dumbledore's you guys
really know how to baby a baby i mean
it's incredible not that it's all five
star i have to say she's got a lot of
issues we'll talk about that later oh my
gosh i can't believe this
hey want to go scare the crap out of mom
daddy please stay focused
right right right there's a crisis at
baby corps what is it this time
kittens no this time it's even worse
worse than kittens
yes that's why i volunteered for this
super secret assignment
who i want to help what do you want me
to do that's the spirit daddy
you are exactly who i need yes to get
uncle ted no what
what what's with the face daddy baby
corp can't wait any longer
all the pressures on me pop when i
volunteered for this gig
i thought it would be easy but you two
never see each other
it's so sad it's like f minus see me
after class
yeah maybe a little i don't know did you
forget to call him
i noticed you can be a little
absent-minded sorry what it's just
you tend to procrastinate you have to
get him here for the holidays
no i'm not no i'm not gonna call him
right now daddy can't never could
did you two have a fight or something oh
but you're mad at him
stop that it's complicated why
do you need help using your phone no i
don't need help using my okay what's the
problem what's the issue
talk to me there's no point okay i call
him i invite him he never shows up he's
always got a work meeting or a business
trip or a
conference paul all he cares about is
work
but after a while yeah you just stopped
trying
he's still your brother you were
partners
yeah i guess sometimes you just you grow
up
and grow apart
daddy don't say no what if everybody
said no
nothing would happen nothing would get
off the ground you got to wake up every
day and you got to say yes
yes yes surprise me say yes
this is really disappointing and now i'm
getting mad
it's late we can work on this tomorrow
okay
oh whoopsie your little horsey fell off
another day won't hurt right good night
sweetie
good night sweetie horsey fell off
tabitha